[MUSIC PLAYING]
So now that we have this OAuth
2.0 access token, I'm going to
show you something cool
we can do with it.
So I'm going to switch
to my browser here.
And I'm going to open up
an incognito window.
Now, don't worry.
This is still safe for work.
And I'm just going to
go to gmail.com.
Now, you'll notice that in
this browser window,
I'm not signed in.
Google has no idea who I am.
But let's do something.
I'm going to go to
https://www.googleapis.com--
oh, here it is--
games/v1/players/me.
And well, at this point, I'm
getting back something that
looks like sort of an error.
And I guess that's not
very interesting.
But let me show you something.
I'm going to add in
?access_token=, and I'm going
to go back to Xcode.
And I'm going to copy this
access token, go back here,
and paste it into the URL.
And look at that.
We get back information
about me.
We get back my ID, my name, the
URL of my avatar image.
Now, we're getting this
information directly from the
Play Games service.
And maybe this seems
normal to you.
Or maybe you're saying,
wait a minute.
You're able to access the Play
Games service by hitting up
web pages in your browser?
What kind of crazy
magic is this?
And that brings us to--
da-da-da-dah--
a somewhat oversimplified, and
inaccurate in places, but good
enough for most intents and
purposes, guide to REST.
And as an added bonus, this
presentation adds
with a bit of a lie.
And we'll get to
that in a bit.
But first, let's talk about what
we mean when we say that
the Play Games service
is a RESTful service.
This is a phrase we throw around
a lot here at Google
because we are a web
services company.
And this is second
nature to us.
But I realize that to many of
you out there, you're game
developers.
You're focused on client-side
issues, like AI, and physics
engines, and multiplying
matrices, and stuff like that.
And you're thinking,
server side stuff?
I don't got time for that.
I'm too busy trying to figure
out path finding, or whatever.
So we're going to go over
what it means to
be a RESTful service.
And if this feels too basic
for you, you feel like you
have a basic understanding of
this, feel free to skip to the
next video.
I won't be offended--
too much.
But let's talk about what a
REST service really is.
I suppose, at its very basic
core, REST is simply a set of
rules about client-server
communication that, very
typically, is paired with HTTP
as its application protocol.
In theory, these two things
don't have to go together.
But in practice, very often, if
somebody's talking about a
REST service, they're talking
about a service that uses
HTTP, which is that application
protocol that your
browser uses.
Which is great for us, because
it means that just about any
language that wants some
basic, web-browser-like
functionality, already has some
really nice support for
making HTTP calls.
And by extension, has great
support for communicating with
servers in a RESTful way.
So the Play Games service,
typically, uses
four types of calls.
GET and POST should be pretty
familiar to you if you've done
anything on the internet.
Two other calls that we use a
little less frequently are PUT
and DELETE.
And let's go over what
each of these means.
GET is generally used to
query the service.
It's used to get information
about a particular thing or
get a list of things.
POST and PUT but are both used
to create a new object or to
update an existing object
on the server.
This is used, say, if you want
to add or modify data up on
the Play Games service.
And DELETE, as they might
suggest, is used
for deleting things.
In case you're saying to
yourself, hey, POST and PUT
look kind of similar.
What's the difference?
The main difference is that
PUT is an idempotent call.
And what does that mean?
Well, that means that if you
make the same PUT call over
and over again, the result
on the server will
always be the same.
Let's say, for instance, that I
had a call to add an item to
a shopping cart.
If every time I made that call,
another item were added
to that shopping cart, that
would not be idempotent.
I would go from one, to two,
to three, to four, to five
bottles of shampoo.
And that would, then,
be a POST call.
On the other hand, if making
that call repeatedly still
only put one bottle of shampoo
in my shopping cart, then that
would be a PUT call.
Perhaps another way to think
about it is POST is typically
telling the server, hey, here's
this update I'd like
you to apply.
Go ahead and supply your own
logic, because maybe there's
other side effects that this
call is going to make.
Whereas, PUT is generally
telling the service, hey, just
copy and paste this data
over what you've got.
Try not to think about
it too much.
Another analogy I've heard that
I kind of like is, PUT is
like setting an instance
variable directly.
You know, we're going to call
some value equals 5.
Whereas, POST is like
calling the setter.
Maybe all it's going to
do is set that value.
But maybe there's other
stuff going on that
we don't know about.
Whichever analogy works
for you, go with it.
And again, this whole thing,
somewhat oversimplified.
So it's time for a
little pop quiz.
Here's a bunch of calls we're
going to make to the service.
See if you can guess what types
of calls these would be.
So, listing all achievements,
well, that is simply querying
the service and getting
back some data.
So that's a GET call.
Getting information about a
particular player, well,
that's also a GET call.
A giveaway might be the fact
that we use the word "get"
right there on the left.
So keep that in mind.
Incrementing an achievement,
that's a POST call.
And if you think about it,
that kind of makes sense.
If we had an achievement to,
say, earn 100 coins, and we
made a call to increment that
achievement by five coins, you
would expect that every time
we made that call.
It would go from five coins
to 10 coins, to 15,
to 20, and so on.
Right?
That call is not idempotent.
It would be different every
time we made that call.
How about unlocking
an achievement?
Now, if you were to say PUT,
you might be right.
And our judges will give
you credit for that.
Because, if you think about it,
if you were to make that
unlock achievement call
multiple times, that
achievement would still
stay unlocked.
Basically, nothing else on
our service changes.
And so that would be
an idempotent call.
However, in a Play Games case,
this is actually a POST.
And I believe the reason is
the team wanted to leave
things open for future
functionality.
Imagine that we had an
achievement that you could
unlock multiple times.
By keeping this as a POST, we
basically leave the door open
to add that feature in the
future without breaking
backwards compatibility.
But maybe this is a good time
to remind you that if you're
ever wondering about these
calls, don't try and guess.
Don't figure it out yourself.
We have API documentation
that you can review.
And you should always
check that out.
And updating cloud saved data,
in this case, it is a PUT.
Because, generally speaking, the
service doesn't know much
about this cloud save data
that we're giving it.
All it does is it copies and
pastes this blob of text that
we're giving it on top of
the save game slot.
And if we ask to save the same
set of data multiple times,
that data doesn't change
on the service.
So let's go back and review
that call we made at the
beginning of this lesson.
This was a plain old GET call
to googleapis.com/g
ames/v1/players/me.
Technically, this looks like
we're accessing a web page.
But really, we're not.
Instead of hitting a
web server, we're
hitting a REST server.
It just so happens that our
browser, which communicates
via HTTP, knows exactly
how to make a GET
call to that service.
And that service spits
back data--
in this case, JSON--
that our browser knows how to
render and display in a
human-readable way.
And if it seems weird that we're
kind of blurring the
lines between accessing a REST
service and hitting web
server, this is basically
a good thing.
One of the nice advantages of
accessing a REST service over
HTTP is that you can do things
like ping the service directly
in your browser or
make a curl call.
And you can analyze the data
that way without having to
write your own client that's
just made to access the Play
Games service.
So that's kind of cool.
You'll also notice, by the way,
that this call did not
work until we added
our access token.
And remember, that
is our valet key
that does two things.
One, it tells the service
who this me string
actually refers to.
The service is able to say,
oh, this key is associated
with Todd Kerpelman's account.
Therefore, we must be
talking about him.
Second, it tells the service
that I've given the Gets My
Number application permission
to find out who I am and
retrieve basic information about
me, like my avatar image
and my player ID.
And remember that I did this
all in an incognito window.
So this access key was,
basically, the only thing the
service had to go on to know
that the person who made this
call was Todd Kerpelman.
And this means you have to be
pretty careful about these
access tokens.
If someone else were to see
this video in the next 60
minutes and they copied that
access token, they could
essentially hit the Play Games
service pretending that they
were me because they have
my access token.
That token is really
the only thing that
identifies who I am.
There's a reason it's called
a bearer token.
And that's because the powers
of that key are associated
with the owner, or bearer,
of that token.
And so you need to treat these
things with the same kind of
respect you would treat
a password.
That means, for starters, don't
go displaying it in
YouTube videos where anybody
could copy and paste it.
That would be a terrible idea.
In practice, this means you
would not add it as a URL
argument the way I did.
You would, more typically, send
the access token as an
HTTP header.
And most importantly, any call
you make where you use an
access token should always
be over SSL.
In fact, if I go back to my
browser, and I were to replace
this HTTPS with HTTP, I'll get
back an error telling me,
sorry, you have to make
this call over SSL.
There are a few other
interesting characteristics of
REST services.
I suppose your definition
of interesting may vary.
The first is that calls are
stateless, meaning the service
doesn't remember who you are
from one call to the next.
In some ways, maybe this
seems like a drawback.
Because every time you make a
call to the service, you need
to send your access token.
You need to resend any
information that the service
should know about the player.
There are no shortcuts
to, hey.
Remember, it's me.
Here's another call
I'd like to make.
The big advantage is that
this makes calls--
in particular GET calls--
very cacheable.
And typically speaking, a lot of
calls you're making through
the Game Service tend
to be GET calls.
So this helps speed up
things quite a bit.
I suppose, somewhat related to
that fact, is the fact that
GET calls will have no
effect on your data.
If your player were to view
their achievements 50 times,
there would be no effect
on their achievements.
These calls are considered
safe.
As mentioned, PUT calls
are idempotent,
as are DELETE calls.
You can delete an object
multiple times.
And calling DELETE a second
or third time won't
undelete the object.
It'll just stay deleted.
Typically, what you get back is
human-readable JSON or XML.
I don't know if this is
a hard and fast rule.
This is by convention.
And again, this makes debugging
really nice and easy.
You can see exactly what you're
getting back from the
service without having to
interpret it, or run it
through any other tools,
or anything like that.
And perhaps, more importantly,
libraries exist for managing
all this stuff, and you
should use them.
We'll talk a little more about
these libraries and the types
you'll be encountering
in the next lesson.
So stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]